Now that we have expanded our keyword list, I'm going to give you a list of rules that
we follow when we are writing content.
Whether you're going to outsource the content to someone or you're writing it yourself,
we still follow these rules and they're very basic rules that we follow by.
One piece of advice is I would actually, if this is the first website that you're starting
on, I would actually write the content myself.
I know it's a pain, but by doing so, you know exactly what you're going to outsource and
it's always better to know what you're doing before you give that word to someone else
because that way you can set expectations and you know what you want back.
So here's starting, let's start, I'm going to write a paragraph.
So again, we use Basecamp.
All right.
So I created a new doc.
I'm actually going to, I usually keep them separate for each page.
So we're going to talk about this later, but each page, I would probably keep it a separate
doc.
I'm talking about the content.
So homepage, content, name it whatever you want.
Okay.
And let's just start with a little paragraph so you can kind of get an idea.
So number one rule is the first word of your paragraph, especially on the homepage, especially
the very top paragraph, the one that we put that little corner image, you want it to be
a keyword.
So if you're, if your website is Queen concrete or whatever it is, you probably want to be
saying something like Queen Creek concrete.
Or you can even, cause you always, so one of the rules is you actually want to sound
like you own the company.
So you don't want to sound like a third person or a third party or just in a weird way, you
always want to sound like you are the owner of the company.
So you can say something like here at Queen Creek concrete and remember that your company
name is going to be the location and the service.
Keep it simple.
So in my case, it's Queen Creek concrete.
If it was in Las Vegas concrete, I would just say here at Las Vegas concrete and keep that
consistent because if you change the name within the content, you're going to sound
unprofessional.
So you want to keep it consistent and keep the name of the company that you have assigned
yourself the same as in the header, the same as in the content everywhere, the same as
in the, in the GMB everywhere.
You are called Queen Creek concrete.
Just keep it consistent.
Do not have 10 names because an actual company would have one name only.
Okay.
So here we go here at Queen Creek concrete, we, and again, talk as if you were part of
the company, we at, we offer service, we offer all types of residential and commercial concrete
services and then whether, whether you are looking for concrete driveway or concrete
patio, we have got you covered.
Okay.
I'm going to pause and kind of read you some of the rules that we have.
So number one, again, start with a keyword.
Okay.
Queen, Queen Creek concrete is a keyword because we have the location and the service.
Another one would be to create a bullet list and I would keep it one bullet list or a number
list, whatever list you want to do per 1000 words.
And what that is, is you don't want to start with a bullet list that looks a little silly.
So after you've read a couple of sentences, you can put something like here are some,
we'll keep a space in between.
Okay.
Here are some of the top services that our local contract, contract tours cover.
And here's where we do the bullet list.
The reason why we do a bullet list is because it's a very easy way to add keywords.
Okay.
We can put concrete driveway, stand concrete, concrete patio, concrete, I don't know, decorative
concrete, whatever it is, whatever your company you really want to rank for.
And you can, you can make it longer.
Of course, don't make like a two, two little items or a thousand, like keep it smooth and
professional.
Another, another easy way to get some ideas on what content to write.
You can actually get on Google and if you type concrete driveway near me, which is what
we're trying to go after.
And I'm sure you guys have seen this before.
If you go down here where it says people ask for, Google will give you an idea of what
people are looking for and their writing.
So you can even write these rhetorical questions within your content.
That's a very easy way you can.
So this one would be a great question because you can, and this is a really easy way to
get ideas on what content you're going to write about this subject.
Okay.
This is a great question.
What is stamped concrete driveway?
Okay.
So you can put that in here.
And again, we'll rearrange the content to run smooth.
What is stamped concrete driveway?
This could be one of our titles in the content and then you go and answer and say, stamped
concrete driveway is a great way to personalize and get the exact look that you have been
looking for in a driveway.
What is stamped concrete?
Our professional constructors will be able to give your concrete any texture.
I think they can do color too.
You want, I think, a type of the card of color, different pattern, textures, and color.
Okay.
We can add pattern as well.
Texture, pattern, and color.
So they can make concrete look like stone, but they can make concrete, you know, have
any type of pattern.
And that's really cool.
So that's a great way to add some content right there.
And this is a great tool.
And the more you actually expand these questions, the more questions come up.
So this is a very, very good idea.
One rule that we also usually follow is try to avoid the word cheap.
So we don't really put cheap concrete service.
That sounds like it's not really good quality.
So instead of using words like cheap, we use affordable.
Just be smart about the words that you're using.
Don't make it sound like you're Walmart, but make it sound like your actual professional
local company.
So then we have do not use more than 10 of the same keywords per thousand words.
That's why we expanded the keyword list.
So do not use the same 10 keywords per thousand words.
And that includes the location as well.
So not just concrete patio, but also don't keep saying here in New York, here in New
York, here in New York, or here in Queen Creek.
Do not keep repeating that more than 10 times per thousand words.
And I'm actually going to show you some resources and tools that you can use to track that down.
And then use both short tail and long tail keywords.
So make sure you are using something very short like concrete patio as a keyword, but
also you're also using something more lengthy like concrete driveway repair here in Queen
Creek, Arizona.
That would be a long tail.
They're both important.
Make sure after you're done writing your content, if you're writing the content yourself, you
probably know whether you plagiarize the content or you've wrote it yourself.
If you are outsourcing, make sure that you're checking the plagiarism and you're not copying
and pasting content from anywhere else.
This will really penalize you.
And you want to keep the plagiarism percentage below four percent.
Make sure, again, the company name, in my case, Queen Creek Concrete, that it's on your
header is always consistent everywhere.
Include the phone number in your content.
So like something that I really like, I think it's very easy and a good way, a good rule of thumb
would be to add the phone number once, at least once every thousand words.
And that's a very easy way.
You could say something like whether you're looking for a concrete driver or concrete patio,
we've got you covered.
And if you want to receive a free instant quote, get in touch with us by calling the following number.
And here's where you're going to add the phone number that we got from CarRail.
If I can find it.
Anyway, I'll add it in later.
I'll just put X, X, X, X, X, because I know that will mean adding the phone number.
OK, next rule, spell check everything.
A really good tool to have.
It's actually Grammarly.
So Grammarly, I'm pretty sure you have to pay for it.
There may be free tryout, but this is what it is.
You can actually add it on as an extension and it will follow you wherever you are,
whatever you have Basecamp or your website builder.
And not only it will spell check every word, but it will also rephrase the sentences to make them better.
So that's a very easy way to spell check and actually make the sentences.
And it will also correct like the punctuation.
So it's a really great tool to have.
And then again, write as if you were the owner.
Don't make jokes.
Don't try to be funny.
Again, we're not writing this to be entertaining.
Be simple.
Keep sentences short.
Keep it simple.
Don't plagiarize the content.
Make it like it's just a simple description of what the company does and what you do and what you offer.
And keep the keyword density.
What we talked about earlier.
Do not use the same keyword more than 10 times per thousand word.
Another way of looking at it is keep the keyword density less than five percent.
And here is a really good tool for that.
You can also use this to check for plagiarism.
It's free.
So just go on SEO review tools dot com and then you're going to add that one.
Let's do keyword density checker.
OK, it's super easy because you just put in so you can do the text input.
You can also put the domain that you have.
In my case, it would probably be text input because I haven't copied the content to my website.
So I'm actually just going to do this copy and paste it in here.
Perform check.
OK, see, I already need to edit my content because I've said that I know that you're like, OK, well, it's 10 times the actual extension of the keyword or the short keyword.
And I would say the short.
So I said concrete way too much.
The density right here is 19 percent and we want to keep it less than five.
So go ahead and go in and add more sentences, maybe some sentences that don't have keywords just to make it less.
And again, keep that less than five.
And then another another tool that we use is actually the duplicate content.
Cancel that part out and just type duplicate content.
Oops. Maybe click right here should give you the option duplicate content checker.
And that's the same thing. You can go ahead and plug in your domain at the very end if that's easier or you can text input your stuff.
Perform check.
And this one, you want to keep below four percent.
Perfect. There is no duplicates. Of course, we just wrote that.
And that is that is it for content.